econ the communicators a discussion
about the government's preparations for
the conversion to digital television
with Vermont senator Bernie Sanders this
week on the communicators our guest is
senator Bernie Sanders an independent of
Vermont senator Sanders we're about a
month out from the analog to digital
transition nationwide what has been your
approach to the DTV transition and also
are you hearing from constituents about
this we are hearing from constituents
there's a lot of concern we held a town
meeting on just this issue in burlington
vermont in late october this is the
concern the concern above and beyond the
fact that the federal government has run
out of money to provide the forty
dollars for the converter boxes is that
i worry very much that on februari a
teeth they after the transition millions
of americans including a lot of
lower-income people a lot of senior
citizens are going to turn on their
television you know what they're going
to see nothing they're going to see
nothing or they're going to see fewer
channels than they previously had these
are folks who today don't have a lot of
money don't want a lot of TV perhaps but
I getting off air TV stations right now
and because of this transition and
because of the geographical terrain in
which they live my state is a very hilly
state they may lose all reception or
some of the channels it is clear to me
that the Bush administration and and the
Congress are not prepared for this
transition and we've got to be
aggressive right now in addressing the
problems did Congress not appropriate
enough money to begin with 1.4 billion
for this transition is not enough money
whether it's Congress or the Bush
administration's fault I'm not sure my
understanding is that the Bush
administration until very recently did
not indicate that they needed the
hundreds of millions of dollars more
than they do need but above and beyond
that issue which is important is I think
there has not been the kind of
preparation are for the many millions of
people who may in fact lose all
reception or some of the networks that
they're currently getting Sanjay tell
wani of TV technology is also here to
question senator Sanders I yeah there's
a few issues here we're going
I think the the reception and antenna
issue as you mention a major problem of
course there's a problem now we're
finding at the eleventh hour despite
repeated warnings that there are that
there is a zero money left for converter
boxes of and they're hoping to recycle
the money back in from expired coupons
they're accumulating people are
weightless at the rate of hundreds of
thousands a day starting last week and
as you as you mentioned there's
reception problems and you know we're
kind of wandering in the in the TV and
broadcasting business you know what's
going to be done for all these people
who don't just need a converter box it
may have followed all the rules gotten
all the education they do everything
right plug in the box and they still
have less than they had before and to us
that's a problem that has only really
been acknowledged by the SEC and others
a little late in the game and I guess
we're leaving it to maybe you in
Congress to well we introduced and I
think you're exactly right subject it is
amazing to me it really is that I I
think members of Congress are going to
be it in for a very big surprise on
februari team they're going to get a lot
of telephone calls from constituents
saying excuse me I just don't want to
have any TV reception at all now what we
did is introduced last session I think
the most comprehensive approach to this
problem which did a couple of things
addressing the problems that sunjai
correctly pointed out number one or what
we said is for perhaps and nobody knows
exactly how many people but perhaps
millions of people they're going to all
of the right things with a converter box
etc they're still going to get poor or
no reception they're going to need an
antenna to go up on their roof or a
better indoor antenna it seems to me and
the basic principle that I'm operating
under the federal government made this
decision and we should not be putting
the cost on to individuals who really
were quite content with the affair TV
that they currently have they should not
have to pick up a lot of expense so what
we said is if you are not getting the
kind of reception that you previously
got federal government should put in
more money
up to eighty dollars more so that if you
have to install a Nintendo on your roof
we will pay for that if you need some
help doing it I worry mostly about older
people lower-income people are and in
the winter time by the way in Vermont in
February's not a great time to be
installing antennas on your roof that's
number one now what happens if even
after you do all of that if you're able
to do is they don't get the reception
that you need but we have said in our
legislation is two things number one if
you can get cable and in my state in
many rural states a lot of people can't
get cable but if you can get tape cable
when our legislation says is that the
cable companies should provide are what
we call a lifeline service a minimum
service which will at least provide what
people are now getting off of the air
and we said that the charge should not
be higher than ten dollars a month now
the good news on that is that comcast at
least has come up with an approach like
that what I worry about knowing comcast
is that they'll use it as a promotional
effort to bring people in and the second
year they'll double the rates the twenty
or thirty or fifty dollars a month we
don't want that we think that the rates
people have a right to get TV reception
because TV today is not just the luxury
TV is how you learn about the world is
how you learn about the weather it's how
you learn about tragedies that are
taking place and especially for many
elderly people it's their their contact
with the world are and then we also said
that satellite companies should also be
also providing a lifeline minimum cost
service now the good news there is that
dish has also come up with a nine dollar
99 cent approach although there's an
installation cost but we worry about
what they will do the second year as
well so those are the two things we're
saying let's give people more money if
they need outdoor antennas let's also
demand that cable companies and
satellite companies provide lifeline
service so that people can at least get
what they are currently respeaking about
your lifeline service senator Sanders ed
you use the word indefinitely in that in
that legislation correct yes I has it
any chance of passing and would it be
able to take effect before februari 17
okay one of the things that has amazed
me and I signed you may want to comment
on this is how relatively little
attention has been paid to this issue
until very recently but I think the
Obama people are aware of the problem
and more and more members of Congress
are now catching on are so I I can't
predict the fate of our legislation I
know that in the house similar
legislation to mind is being introduced
there is certainly increased discussion
there is even frankly some discussion
about delaying the implementation of
this plan because the perception is that
the Bush administration through the
overall and competence has left us in a
position we were just not ready for this
transition do you foresee the Congress
delaying the februari 17th date I think
it's an issue that's being discussed I
can't give you a prediction on it but I
think that I mean just from a political
point of view you don't want to be the
congressman or the senator I have to
take the phone calls from people who've
lost their reception and say you know
television is important to my life I'm
an elderly person that's what I did why
did you impose regulations that make me
lose my TV I mean we're supposed to be
moving forward not back with you know
we've had TV for about 50 years to take
it away from millions of people is not a
very sensible proposal you know it which
raises a question of what are we going
to do on februari 18th to handle what
could be an outcry people are going to
be calling us they see people put any
calling your office they're going to
call whoever they feel is to blame and
part of the answer may come from the
local stations the state association to
state broadcasting associations because
they've really focused their outreach to
be more more locally relevant and
they've developed call centers that
respond more appropriately to to
people's concerns because if you call
from a certain geographic area they can
say oh yes a lot of people having
reception problems there you may need a
new antenna you may need to get
satellite so you know a question forum
for Congress and for the FCC is exactly
you know what do you do on that day
every 18 when you get by some estimates
as many as
2 million phone calls not just two
million people who are losing the
surface and are disappointed in seeing
snow on their TV and there's talk of
call centers but we don't know if those
even those calls their people be even
more frustrated if they if they call and
get kind of a hold or a senator Sanders
well I think the local stations have
been trying very hard and effectively to
educate people about what's going on but
you can educate people but the point you
made a few moments ago is if somebody
does all of the right things they're
well educated they respond to their
information they've gotten they still
may end up with fewer stations are or
with no stations at all my hope is that
by februari 18th Congress will have
already done the right thing now whether
that can happen in such a short period
of time in such a momentous moment when
we're dealing with so many other issues
remains to be seen so it's either
pushing back the transition date or end
making sure that when somebody calls but
the person at the other end of the line
can say okay two things i want you to
call this number because your cable TV
company will provide you with an
inexpensive lifeline service as will
your satellite company and in addition
to that if you don't want to do that
we're going to make more money available
to you so you can have a better quality
antenna that should help well and
current of Vermont Public Television is
joining us from Vermont and curran are
you prepared for X number of phone calls
on februari 18 well actually we just met
the local stations group in Vermont and
in the Plattsburgh area of New York
that's part of the market had a meeting
to talk about that our hope is that we
can staff a local call center because
our experience with doing tests and
doing local call insets that people
really want local information and
silvermont public television has agreed
to be the host for a call center if we
have the staffing support that we know
will get from the other stations and and
the financial support to share expenses
and where do you get that financial
support we'll all have to chip in and
unless there's some something in the way
of some federal money subsidizing this
we will all chip in and make our own
staff available that's the plan right
now to have our own call takers and our
own technicians at the bpt studio to
answer questions and to share the phone
expenses which you know which could be
significant but we have six stations
involved and we've been sharing expenses
six ways and all the various activities
that we've been doing and currently
Vermont conducted a soft test of the
digital transition correct we did on
December 16th this was really an
unprecedented effort to have all of the
affiliates the CBS NBC ABC fox and to
PBS stations our station and the station
based in Plattsburgh New York Mountain
Lake PBS were staffing the phones we had
about 44 call takers between the two
sites here at the two PBS stations
because as most people know PBS stations
are usually pretty well armed with
telephones and so we were the natural
place to host it and we had about a
dozen technicians who spent a lot of
time on the phone with individuals
trying to address and help them with
their very specific technical questions
and in charin what would you what would
your message be to senator Sanders well
greeting senator Sanders on how are you
I'm very well and we are working kind of
one viewer at a time right now Vermont
Public Television had our third play of
a one-hour call-in program this week and
once again we were flooded with calls
for an hour but I am I'm excited about
the idea that people may be able to get
some financial help with and with
coupons making more coupons available if
that's possible making antenna coupons
available would be very excited about
that and of course any kind of
affordable cable or satellite service
would be just great because we take so
many of the phone calls that we hear
from people who for them you know it may
be buying a converter box or two with a
coupon is manageable but when when we
start having
tell them that in many cases they're
going to have to consider a better
indoor antenna or maybe an outdoor
antenna and someone to install it that
begins to talk about possibly hundreds
of dollars and that's a it's a real
challenge for people especially in
today's economy well and makes first of
all I want to congratulate an in Vermont
Public Television like that we helped us
in the town meeting that we put on in
October they have been doing a very
conscientious job but the point that and
makes is that by and large in 2009 if
you don't have satellite today if you
don't have cable and it is accessible to
you there's a reason for it and perhaps
you can't afford it so the point that an
is making is that a lot of the people
who are going to be in trouble now don't
have a lot of money and if you say to
them well gee you're going to have to
get satellite that's not really a good
answer if you're a senior citizen living
on Social Security or you're a
low-income person so I think it is
obligatory for the federal government
this act did not come from God it came
from the federal government who said
that on a certain date as a transition
and tough luck to you well that's wrong
so we have got to support those people
who need the financial help to make this
transition Sanjay tolani um a question
for 4n maybe you can get some advice to
a productive what you're going to do as
the big day draws closer and advice
maybe for other broadcasters especially
larger markets helping people one by one
and even having staff going out to help
some people is great but in larger
markets helping hundreds of thousands of
individuals one by one and sending
technisat our house isn't practical and
then on a more practical a more local
level you may have a well-staffed call
center now but you of course you'll have
a much higher volume of calls when the
signal actually disappears and you're
running a there's a snow on the analog
signal or a slate that says call a
certain number so do you have any any
plans or any means to really uptick this
outreach uptick these call centers and
also what what do you see that that the
bigger market stations which will
obviously many more calls you know what
what can they do is I how do you how do
you look at this upcoming and current
well there are models all over the
country as for what some of the larger
model larger stations and statewide
services are doing some have already
contracted with with professional call
center services where they can you know
agree that they will have up to a
certain number of people being able to
answer calls at the same time we have a
little bit of information from the
markets that shut down their analog
early which which to me was somewhat
reassuring and that people are not all
calling it once they tend to have peaks
and valleys and call around some of the
most popular shows so I think the best
any of us can do is to try to gauge by
the percentages we think maybe unready
in our markets and then look at where
the points in our schedules will be that
you'll have the highest number of calls
and people wondering what happened or
how to get a station and staff for that
but there's there's no doubt that any of
us is best we plan could be overwhelmed
and have to take messages and have
people leave a phone number and know
that they will be getting back because
these these technical conversations
we've learned can go on for ten minutes
or so before the viewer really
understands what he or she should be
trying to do and sometimes they want you
to stay right on the phone with them
while they try rescanning or doing
something and we're we're happy to do
that and try to get them through this
and of course people are very grateful
when they get that kind of local help
well I think we're dealing with two
separate issues here number one is the
calling stations so that when people
call up somebody is at the other end of
the line who can explain to them what is
going on what they might have to do but
the second issue which is a lot more
difficult you talk about sending out
people to help well you know what in a
rural area where where people may be
separated by 20 or 30 miles and you got
to go to a house by house that and in an
urban area would maybe a whole lot of
people that is an expensive proposition
uh and and that's what we haven't
figured out so number one yeah we got to
explain to people you can explain to
people and then
need help and that second part is what
worries me most that's true and none of
our local stations in in Vermont and the
northeast part of New York are staffed
to be able to send technicians out into
the homes we have also been in touch
with certain organizations that do some
outreach and have even done a little bit
of training with one of them to try to
let people who direct do direct service
with elders and so forth learn how to
install a converter box but that only
gets you so far and it is a real
challenge that we we do maintain a list
of antenna technicians by locality that
we can refer people to but of course
those folks may be very very busy i rana
CLE if I might this is in terms of the
stimulus package you want to talk about
job creation you can create some jobs
hiring people to do just that and that's
an issue will be pushing as well this is
a question for both senator Sanders and
for and current has the FCC been helpful
in this transition and anchoring when
you call the FCC with questions or the
ntia with questions have you gotten good
responses question for both of you well
I guess from a station perspective it's
it's somewhat mixed the there is
wonderful information available from
both of those programs but there are
some like if you want to know how to
hook up a converter box with a VCR
you'll find wonderful information on the
FCC's site and I know that they are
staffing of their own call center and
information there certainly has been
problems with on both sides some of it
being I think a little bit late to the
game as far as realizing that they
needed to actually in some cases require
stations that hasn't been the case in
our market we were out there in front
pretty early but in some markets they've
actually mandated that stations have to
put on a certain number of spots and
certain half-hour informational programs
and do some of that and then on the
coupon side there have been obviously
some real problems here in a rural state
we've had so many people who have post
office boxes who early in the stage is
that the coupon program were denied and
and then I often have talked to people
who've been denied for sometimes
unexplained reasons who just got shut
out and don't have coupons and really
need them so we've been kind of
collecting them from some of our friends
and relatives and trying to make them
available to people as best we could
well I agree with and I think but
overall I think the proof is in the
pudding if what I think many people are
concluding we're not ready for this
transition who is responsible for not
being ready and that has to be the Bush
administration and the FCC I know
Michael cops one of the commissioners
was in Vermont talking about this issue
and I think some of the people they're
trying to do the right thing but overall
if you run out of coupons if millions of
people may lose reception somebody's has
to be held accountable and I think it
would not shock many viewers to know
that we don't have a particularly
competent administration on the
President Bush and shouldn't be
surprised that they failed once again I
think there were a lot of preparation
issues and a lot of the consumer groups
are now kind of saying I told you so on
some of these matters there were
warnings that the coupon program would
run out of out of money and they
Congress repeatedly asked NTIA which is
administering the coupon program if they
had enough money and it was only in the
last couple of months where they said
yes we do need more money right after
the new year they ran out there were
technical things that broadcasters may
have been able to do some new types of
transmission systems broadcasters were
pushing for this some some people within
the government were pushing for this but
it was only very late in the game late
last year that the FCC started making
rules for some of these systems for what
a system called distributed transmission
system and and the translator says it
was essentially to oversimplify
basically means putting up more towers
and sending out signals to cover dark
areas the chairman of the FCC Kevin
Martin for a long time was a little bit
dismissive of the notion that people who
did all the right things would not
simply because of the way the signals go
would simply not get a digital TV signal
where for 40 50 years
they'd gotten an analog signal so
obviously agree with senator Sanders
that there has been a lot of frustration
and I guess the question is now a
best-case scenario the coupons comes
four to six weeks after their ordered
that's we're outside that window even if
you passed legislation tomorrow for some
kind of an antenna program antenna
subsidy program we're kind of looking at
a little far out there and we're going
to have a big gap where people lose TV
and as you said these are some of the
most vulnerable people they're people
who don't use the internet there are
people who are elderly or people who
don't speak English they're people who
are poor they're people who live in
rural areas that don't have the cable
option and you know may not want the
hassle of addition and they might my
question to a question to Senator would
be given the current climate given all
the priorities and the demands for money
and given that there's some people who
are fielded too much money has already
been thrown at this program what are the
you know chances to kind of uptick this
with more with with this antenna program
which sounds going to a lot of people
particularly antenna makers well they
answer you a question yeah we have an
economy that's collapsing their health
care system that's falling apart we have
a war in the Middle East so now I wanted
to other problems out there on the other
hand politicians being what we are we do
know that if somebody turns on the TV
and there's nothing that you know what
worry about gossip but you got to worry
about that as well so I think that
although I have been amazed at how slow
members of Congress have responded in
this issue I think you're going to say
AC an accelerated concern because this
is really a political issue and I think
if I were Barack Obama coming into
office the last thing I want a month
into my presidency is millions of people
saying hey you're the president I don't
have any TV anymore what did you do and
Obama's people are very smart I think
they understand this issue so one of the
options that I think people are looking
at it saying hey we haven't gotten our
act together we got
to push this back a little bit longer so
that we can address some of your
concerns well senator that's a that's a
nice transition into the incoming Obama
administration you've been a pretty
vocal advocate of net neutrality and
some other issues what do you expect
from an Obama administration well I
think the issue of media in general and
and the Internet are huge issues for
this country I mean there's a revolution
in communications and certainly the
Internet is in the middle of that and we
do not want to see a continuation of the
process that we're seeing right now
we're a small number of large are
multinational corporations are
controlling the flow of information on
television and newspapers are so I think
you will see within the Obama
administration a very strong effort to
make sure that small entities have the
same possibilities that CNN and the New
York Times and other large entities have
that's very very important to me and I
suspect many people the abomination do
you see net neutrality becoming an issue
again in the next Congress in the 111 I
think so i think the the revolution is
on the internet i don't have to explain
to anybody that fewer people read
newspapers few people are watching
network television so it's an issue that
has to be addressed the goal of course
is to make sure that people have is wide
of range of options on the internet as
possible and those people who develop
websites have the opportunity to
communicate with people around the world
as much as possible and not see that
entity controlled by big money interests
and current of Vermont Public Television
thank you for joining us on this
communicators San Giovanni what is a
soft test a soft test it they've been
calling it a analog shut off test it's
really a simulated shut off in which the
people who are viewing over the air
through through an antenna would instead
of their normal program would get
something else a 30-second a two-minute
a slate or message a screen thing that
says if you see this picture
you're you do not have digital TV and
you need to either get a digital TV set
which you can buy at the store or get a
converter box which you can buy at the
store although actually there's a
Russian converter boxes as well or get
you know get cable or satellite and so
it's um in some ways these outreach
efforts in his educational endeavors
have been enormously successful in that
they have driven demand for the coupons
that's one reason they've running
they're running out of the coupon money
is because of broadcasters and
grassroots groups of the consumer groups
and government agencies have have had a
very heroic effort to get the message
out now they've gotten the message out
there's some issues with the laws of
physics and getting the signal and
there's some issues with the money for
the boxes and supply of boxes so the
softest and they're have an awful lot of
these there'll be a few more sometimes
I'm doing in the whole market was no
matter what channel you're watching
every single one of them you can't
switch another channel you're going to
get this thing so you really have to be
going out of your way if you're a TV
watcher you you have to go out of your
way to have missed a message so the soft
test and of course they develop a spike
in the calls to the station they put a
number they get calls and it's been very
useful for the station's to learn where
their problems are what kind of problems
they're having and actually ninety
percent of the largest number of calls
they've been getting basically soft
tests have been people who simply want
the basic fact of how do i get a
converter box coupon and so senator
sanders information which is not going
to be particularly useful right now
right senator are you satisfied with the
efforts the that sanjay tell bonnie was
describing broadcasters and cable
companies outreach I mean yes and no I
think they have made I know in Vermont
how people have worked very hard to
educate folks but i think they also have
an obligation to raise the red flag that
despite one of the education we have
some very very serious problems in a
very short time frame to address those
problems senator bernie sanders
independent of vermont sanjay tell wanna
of TV technology TV technology com is
the website thank you both for being on
the communicators escrever this is an
issue that the communicators will be
looking at over the next month as we get
closer to februari 17th
you